I've been working as a web developer for a couple of years now
and here globally we've been
working for a little while with what
would become a micro frontend. We've
had a couple of lessons out there and we
want to share a little bit of that
so, well, let
's get started.  Let's see,
analyzing the problem that we have, the one
that we want to attack is something that almost
never happens when we are developing
software.
and then
that makes it a problem to maintain
that piece of software and well, as
if this were not enough, we always
have problems or requirements, such as that they
want us to deliver quickly or that
the software has high
availability, so
that is attracting us as
certain complications in development
so to understand this a little
more or we are going to reflect on how
web development has evolved
so we are going to go back to the
nineties when
all this stuff about the web was just starting and so on it
will be a great invention  back
then we had a single
monolith that single monolith and it was
all integrated database connections
what is sent to the browser
everything is all in one big project
obviously that made it difficult
to maintain brought its own
problems as
time went on
and around there, already a little past the
90s,
someone said hey, why don't we
separate, we're going to make the back end
work on one side and the front end
work separately and/or a big surprise
there was a breakthrough  because it will be
easier to maintain on the one hand and back
end and on the other hand the front end we
keep moving forward and we see what
I have left behind the backend they say it again
ok
this is becoming a problem in
our business logic the
implementations are so complex that
even though  we separated from the front end they
are still a problem to maintain it is
complicated why not instead of having
a single system in the back in a
monolithic system in the back end because we do
not separate it because we do not do
microservices tiny services that
do a specific task
and microservices are born,
the task is simplified and that's why it's
a great success
while that happens with people with the
backend delegated from the front-end,
just the opposite happens
and that's where we started to say hey why
don't we mix everything in a single package that
the front end is served all together out
there the spice began to emerge and we
began to generate some bonzi and others
and well this on its own brings about
certain problems we are not going to put up I
have a page a website that let's not
say it has  five pages and out of
those five pages only one contains an
error and needed to display it again
like but how is it all in one big
bond I can't display that page
by itself so I have to do a
full display of my
entire application again so let's  To
jump to the present, we are not in
the year 2020, this started and it has been a couple
of years,
but well, in 2020 we say, well, why
not instead of having a single
web application, a single package for the
front end, because we do not separate it into  a
lot of little packages
and that's where the question comes from ok
as it happens
with microservices
because we don't do micro frontends
so it will try to show a
hard definition of what a
micro front-end architecture is we
could say that it is the
web development approach in  the front end
is like a composition of small
web applications
and here an important detail is that each
of these small applications must
represent a subdomain of the business
that is like the key for this to be
successful
basically we are not going to divide them what
we are  seeing right now is a
screenshot of my facebook
facebook some years ago around
2010 they published an
article in which they proposed something very
similar to the concept of micro frontend in
fact we could say that that is where it
begins to be coined  the subject the
term
only that they don't call them micro
frontend they call it page led
and basically what they do is
select their application section
facebook in such a way that each section
can be worked on by a
different team when they did that they saw
improvements in performance and  development became more
agile and brought several
advantages but hey let's analyze
the facebook interface a little bit up
here we have the
search box in the menu over
here we have a section to create
posts when stories became fashionable
simply  they added
here
to the page we have the
news section, advertising and the chat on a
single page we have like many
different functionalities
but each of them is
completely isolated
we are going to try to reflect a little on
how those who are
used to using facebook work if they
have  fixed when we click on an
element when we use any of
these elements we are really
using only that element
the others are not altered what I mean by
this let's say I am writing
a publication no I do not see that
the news view is altered for example a
new, which is to alter the
stories section, each section
independent of the others,
let's go into a little more detail, a
little more interesting for
us,
how this looks in the code
using the chrome development tools
on facebook, we are going to see something
similar to  this
is basically ok if we check the
section to create a post we are going
to see that they have this part
called page led composer here what
they did was create a small
application that is specialized in
creating facebook posts not
showing them just creating them the same  It happens
with the stories the stories are a
very particular case because to a certain
extent they have an integration with
instagram
so in this case from behind they
have that communication channel towards
instagram or the stories that are
published within the same
facebook platform and they only consume  that
data and they included it here as a
small separate page led
let's remember page led is like one of the
first terms that was given to something
similar towards a micro front-end
and well we have the news for the
end everything is as a separate application
now  We are going to pay a little
attention to the part of the code if
we look closely there is nothing
impressive what we see is one day and
what part could we say ok that is
just a simple implementation of
components
and to a certain extent it is not  we are
here reinventing nothing in fact we are
using technologies that occur that
have been around sorry for a long time
and we could use it with with deep
over there we could even use it with with
life lips
and well
here the key to this
technique is let's imagine our
websites as if  outside a rack let's
imagine a server rack where
we put each application in one of the
spaces so we could
be connecting disconnecting adding
pieces to our websites and jesse
our website would have to
support it we could extend it to do
it by steps and so on
and not  we should have bigger
repercussions let's remember one of the
key parts is that we have to
imagine it we have to do it in such a
way that each one of our micro
frontends represents a subdomain of the
business and since their level of the business
has to be isolated to some extent
from the  So,
and
we're going to move on to something a little more
interesting, which would be a
demo of how all this works
here, before we start, I would like
to point out that there is no
strict way or definitive technique on
how to implement a micro front-end here.
What we are
doing is more like a philosophy, a
concept of how we are developing
our website,
if there are currently some
frameworks that make this task easier for us,
but we do not necessarily have to
implement them, all we need
is to follow that idea of ​​ok
each section or each subdomain  of my
business is going to be represented by a
mini application separate and isolated from the
rest
so in this case the demo that we are going to
be seeing is a small application
a pending application is a whole
and well in this application we are going to
consider that the team  development has
already analyzed it and then decide where
this application is divided into three parts
the first is the editor the editor is
literal where the user is going to write
the task
the second section is to come making the
list a list of everything they have
written and saved
and the third is simply would
be the rack to talk about oms is a
small application that the only thing it will
do is contain the others
and maintain these connections do all
the wiring that must be done behind
I understand a second here perfect let's
start  reviewing a little, it
is what would be the rack we were
talking about
so all this code is in hip
hop in case you want to review it
later calmly at the end of the
presentation we are going to put the link there
but basically the first part that I
I would like us to review it is ok
lines 18 and 19 we see that we are
using iframe for a few
years now
I have noticed that people do not
like to use james and here is how ok
we are going back to using iframes
because because it is  as the easiest way
we have to embed an
application inside another
and it is a standard it already comes in all
browsers if it is already included in
browsers why not use it again
this depends a lot on your
current development maybe not on your current development
Saray frames suits you so much so you
will have to change this technique
but well for the demo right now with this
enough
as we see here the html is very
simple there are only 2 iframes in one
reference to the editor and we
review we refer to the list
right now we are seeing the  The editor code
here we see that the html is a little more
complex.
Basically we have two of two fields and
two buttons, one for the title, one for the
description, a button to save and another
to clear it,
this clears the note,
then continuing with the assumptions
that we have  been doing so far
we are going to say that this small
application was developed by a
team that team has its own style
of code and its own practices
ok so this team said we are going to
make this micro front or this small
application considering three points
other objects sorry the  first it must
be used as a public road this is
through this object it has to be
connected to my application in another
separate object we are going to manage all the
business rules and in a third object we are going to
tie all this to the graphical interface
and here  I'm going to pass it like this, it's quick
so that you have in the reference when you
see the code in hip hop
here it is perfectly indicated
to play each of these three objects.
Let's remember the idea here is that there is an
object that must be used
as a clean and  public
now we go to the next micro
application or micro fontaine which is the
application of the list
if we see the html again it is the
simplest thing in the world
we have a body with a list element there
is no more here all the trick is
inside the javascript that  I'm going
to add those elements
and this team is a separate team again,
they decided that the
simplest thing to do was ok, we're going to create functions
that handle all of this
and we're going to keep a
small list of elements that we
have to notify each time.  If
an alteration occurs, it does not change in
this list.
If we review both micro applications, they
have as their object their way of
controlling themselves.
They are different ways of controlling themselves,
but they are not in conflict. After all, they
are called between, we can say that they are
called between 12 and different piaf.
returning to our container as
our frame it is
not enough just to include those elements
of the live link we have to do the wiring
and this is as it would happen with any
element of a server rack that
we would do what we will use it is not enough to
just put the server in its place
We have to connect it with,
sorry,
so that happens here below
and if you look closely, it's just that we call
the functions that we defined
in the other mini-applications,
all that wiring occurs and it's
working, we're going to see this working
together,
ok,
this is the application that  we are
developing
if we can
there our application was working
so here until now we have only
seen that these small
applications that we develop get along well but what
is the advantage of this technique we are going to
assume that we already deplore this
production and that is why they tell us hey what do
you think we are done  to discover a small
box that we lost production over there
the task list is turning
red when you hover over it we
have to redeploy but we don't
want to cause a service down over
there we just want to support
that little one again  little bit is a
tiny bug it doesn't cost us anything to fix it
right now
so what we can do here is ok
I'm not going to throw out my whole application anymore
I can come here directly to my
css code this is the css code of the
list
the block arrives review  find the
forest it says it started here
this color property is hard for me I
deleted it and I would have to display it again
so we are going to do this review right now I already made
the change to the
box and I have not displayed it there
for the purposes of the demonstration I did a
little cold script
you can't move
separate applications from within this
topic
already in the real world it could be a
container it could be a virtual machine
it could be whatever and it depends a lot on
your infrastructure how
your services or your application works but this  You
are not fighting with the concept,
well, here I could tell you that it is
sorry
and this is going to display only the
little bit of the list, here we are, we are
seeing it only from the beach, the
list, we
return to our demos, we reload the
page
and that's it, and backwards, we repair the box.  we
could not have slightly
stronger errors we are going to cause one
let's say that for example
somewhere in the list someone made a
mistake
and I am going to a piece of the html that is going to
cause the gel application
to stop working
again we support this end without any
residue  In our this production
we see that the only thing that happened,
as expected, only
that part stopped being painted because it is only an iframe and
it is connected to the rest, but everything
else continues to work
again, we can say ok, I
already found the box, I repaired it.  from
player my problem solved
so here basically the idea is ok we are going to
separate this or we are going to
imagine it as if they were
separate applications we are not inventing anything
new it
is only the perspective with which
we are starting to develop our
applications we are going to see it as
applications separated
by  there the other day someone said to me hey
after all it is a simple
approximation of components and if in a
certain way it is
and you just have to take into account imagine
your components as if they were a
separate application I should be able
to send that to production
single component and in fact it is to accumulate the great
key or the great lesson that we have
learned working in this way here in
global
the great value of working with a micro
front-end lies more than anything in the form
that we have or in the flexibility that
we have  to deplore fractions of
applications there have been occasions in
which we have encountered problems already in
production
in which we only required
to deploy a small piece of application and
working in this way has helped us
as you have no idea it
has also given us a lot of flexibility
at the time of  manipulating or maneuvering
with our applications is never necessary
for the client to tell us, hey, I
told you that you were going to develop this in
this way in the architecture and it will
be like this, but at the last
moment I am realizing that it is not
true  You didn't need it and I need you to
change it and quickly because they are
dates that lived, I had commitments
so having that separation is how it
isolates us from problems, it has given us
too much flexibility
and we return to
the presentation
and it's good
to work in this way and as always it's not
a  definitive solution you have to put
things on the scale, you won some
things but I lose others there are some that
have more weight others have less weight
but yes it is always a matter of
analyzing it if it is the right thing to say what is
indicated that we need for our
project what things can I win
First of all,
organizational flexibility, we are going to have a lot of
flexibility in how we organize ourselves
within our projects.
We gain more scalability and a year and an
infinite number of ways for the player,
it is going to be easier or it could even
become more difficult as much as
we think.  We complicate it for
ourselves, but we are going to have a lot of flexibility
in this way, in the
way in which we find it,
and here one of the points that I like
the most is that in some way
they always come back to  our
projects and when it's a big project
it's a pretty big project it
's always a problem because the
new factors don't know the whole codebase
so the time it takes to learn
that learning curve is too
long or not as smooth as we
would like
working in this way, it smoothed out
a lot because the sections that
a new developer has to focus on
are smaller, they are
specific functionalities, they no longer have to know the
entire code to have a good
performance,
but hey, that's on the one hand because of the
another one that we have because the
complexity grows because because the
complexity grows because we have to
be very aware of which version of
each micro source we are deploying
for example version 1 of our
editor application requires certain
functionalities from the list of elements
that were added  up to version 2
of the list of elements, so
we have to be maintaining that
relationship there, the complexity grows a little
at the moment of
flowing, we have to maintain that relationship
that something else can happen because what do you believe
in the pre-salt that skype sorry  the size
of the transfer bags that we
are going to have, we remember how they are
separate applications, since each one
has its own dependents, they have
to load their own resources, so
the
amount of data that we are
transferring can grow, that is why we must
be careful in this sense
and
another very delicate point is that
we have to put more emphasis on
integration tests again we
are integrating different
applications so it is not only
likely that the application is testing the
applications and
that they get along with each other  them
and well if at this moment they told me
well when would you recommend me to use
this technique or take a micro
frontend approach that I took I would
mainly consider these two aspects
in the first place how diverse in the
business
obviously the business can be so  It's
simple that if I start to
implement a microphone, you understand,
because of the novelty, because I want to try it,
maybe it's just complicating things for me, let's
say a simple business that
is preventing me. At this
moment, a calculator occurs to me
and, well, two applications could say something
one that is like on the
screen and another that is like the buttons
in that scenario so well it
is really useful for you to implement a micro
front-end beyond educational purposes
instead if the business is a little
more diverse let's say a unique  commerce
out there and well out there they are going to tell me
well un and commerce the business
is ultimately sales and if they are
correct but on the one hand there is the
part of the business that is in charge of
showing the products what I am going to
sell is the part of the business that is
the cart and this is the part of the
business that is to make the sale effect
on the transaction
I could develop each of these
parts separately as a separate application
just define as certain communication channels
and
and  In the end, nothing more to unite them as a
single great application
and the other aspect that I would consider is
when there is a possibility that
a fragmented release has to be made, it is
fragmented.
support
only this little bit we find this eye
or we want to add this new
functionality but only in this little bit
we do not want to affect the others so
if there is a possibility of that happening most
likely in micro frontex they are
a good option
and well this is what I would have prepared
for  share here you have the
link to the hop kit where you can
download the presentation of the
demo code which is referenced right there
on my social networks and my website on the
website you can also find my social networks